inflation in the united states sits at a
40-year high the 8.6 reading on the cpi
is something that has surprised
economists and central bankers alike
they previously thought that inflation
had peaked in march because we got a
down reading in april but now all of a
sudden there's been a re-acceleration
and we've hit that 40-year high in
inflation causing the federal reserve to
continue to double and triple down on
their pursuit of tighter financial
conditions now as they raise interest
rates and they begin to conduct
quantitative tightening there are many
people both pundits economists and
central bankers who believe that these
actions will actually bring inflation
down and get it into a more manageable
area
but now we have goldman sachs coming out
and saying they don't necessarily
believe that's what's going to happen
there's a brand new report that's been
released which says inflation may get
much worse this summer and it could
linger for many years
that would not be good as we dig into
exactly what their argument is you can
see here the goldman economists said
that they expect consumer prices to rise
more quickly later this summer due to
transportation and health insurance cost
and that that will push the core
inflation which takes out food and
energy from about six percent in may to
6.3 percent in september they then went
on to state that health insurance and
automobile prices two of the largest
contributors that those should start to
fall by the end of the year and that
could push core inflation down from 5.5
at year end and 2.4
by the end of next year now of course
they're not the only ones who have
thoughts here jeffrey roach over at lpl
financial their chief economist stated
that policymakers must come to grips
with a real possibility that inflation
rates will not come down to their
preferred targets for many years
now at the end of the day whether you
think that inflation has peaked or you
believe that it will remain persistent
that it could accelerate higher and stay
around for many years what we do know is
that the federal reserve and other
people who are in positions of influence
around the economy they're going to
start to take action not necessarily
because they should but because we're
all human and the only way that humans
feel in control is if they're doing
something and so we already have tighter
financial conditions today than we did
just six to eight months ago and the big
question is how much tighter can the
federal reserve make those financial
conditions how much more expensive can
they make capital with the interest
rates increasing and how much less
assets on their balance sheet are they
willing to withstand because if they
continue on the path that they're on
things are going to break we've already
seen many assets draw down anywhere
between 20 to 60 percent
and there's a lot of questions around
how the average american family can
continue to withstand the current
economic environment and so at some
point because of the long-term trends
the federal reserve will have to waive
the white flag they'll have to give up
on this tighter financial conditions and
they'll return to loose monetary policy
the question though is how much demand
can they destroy between now and then
what will be the thing that breaks that
actually causes them to give up on their
current mandate
and what exactly
is going to be the severity and speed at
which they reverse course that federal
reserve pivot it will definitely happen
when it happens and how significant it
is is a big question in the market right
now
inflation is here there's no denying it
plenty of people want to debate how we
got it and even more people want to
debate what we should do going from here
but what i know is that the average
american family is struggling
8.6
cpi is insane
it's not what you expect in a developed
nation with the global reserve currency
like the united states
but here we are and now we're left with
asking ourselves what do we do from here